hello my name is Tara Island I'm the
Regional Director for a chef for Oxfam
and I just want to comment a little bit
on the question around the role of Asian
women clearly as half the population
women play a significant role in
development of any areas but I think
particularly here in Asia where there
are so many entrepreneurs so many highly
skilled women in all sectors of society
they will play a significant role in the
future of Asia I think also involving
women in all spheres social economic and
political will help sustain development
across the region I think it's important
to continue to invest in women so that
means girls education invest in helps
because that impacts mainly on women and
young girls but also to ensure that we
see women taking up valuable roles in
society so we value and recognize the
role that they can play throughout
society so I think finally if we are
really going to eradicate poverty in
East Asia women need to pay a key role
in that it's all of our responsibilities
the business sector the public sector of
government and the role of NGOs to
ensure that women take up their equal
rights within East Asia